Genes, genomes and DNA: these words have slipped
into our daily news cycles and our awareness,
but what they actually mean often remains
unclear.
In these lessons, we aim to give you, not
just the explanation of what a genome is,
but a real-life perspective on why you already
care about genomics – perhaps in ways you
didn’t even realize.
What is a genome?
A genome contains all of the information that
a cell needs to develop, function, and reproduce
itself, and all the information needed for
those cells to come together to form a person,
plant, or animal.
Genomes contain an organism’s complete set
of genes and even tinier genetic structures
that help regulate when and how those genes
are used.
The ability to regrow a torn ligament, the
clues that might predict the onset of mental
illness, the nutritional potential of crops,
and even the history of life itself are all
encoded in genomes.
Genomics is a new science and it tries to
understand all the genetic material that we
have, the genes, as well as tiny structures
that regulate where a gene is turned on, how
active the gene is, and how it contributes
to overall function.
To begin in genomics, everything starts with
DNA.
DNA is the fundamental building block of all
of life.
DNA is a complex molecule.
Think of DNA as a set of letters that form
sentences and eventually these sentences form
paragraphs and these paragraphs form whole
books.
So, we have DNA, and then we have genes that
are made up of pieces of DNA, and then as
we assemble all the genes together, we have
our book of life, the genome.
Genomics is very much technology driven.
We have benefited from an incredibly fast
development of the technology.
The core of genomics lies in sequencing.
It has been amazing to watch the technology
develop very rapidly over the last 30 years.
It's not that long ago that we started with
a very, very tedious process that was done
in individual labs that took hours and hours
to obtain a sequence of maybe 20 or 30 nucleotides
or pieces of the DNA.
Now it's possible to sequence an entire human
genome, which is 3 billion such pieces, in
a few hours.
We've gone through several forms of technology,
and we've also gone through changes in the
organization of the science as a result.
In the early days, everything was done in
individual labs, contributing in small amounts
to the sequencing that we were able to analyze
collectively.
Now we are moving more and more as the technology
advances to centralized facilities with very
expensive equipment that able to handle large
amounts of DNA and perform amazing feats of
sequencing.
Genomics is not just based on sequencing technology.
It is actually spawned a whole other area,
which is called bioinformatics.
Since genomics gathered such huge amounts
of data, it's impossible to use conventional,
statistical approaches, and general data organizing
approaches to handle it all.
As a result, we have a new breed of scientists,
who is expert in biology, expert in computation,
and to be able to bridge the gap and give
us the tools we need to make sense of the
data.
These scientists, bioinformaticians, are incredibly
essential to the whole genomics enterprise.